[Music]
we have a chance to combine music and
art and films all together
we're sponsoring the new band it's
called the velvet underground
[Music]
and me i'm in a rock and roll band
[Music]
that was my first time in new york and i
have support
this place is filthy
[Music]
cinema money parties it was outrageous
people came because the cameras were
running they thought they could become
famous
at the center of it is the exploding art
world
it opened your eyes to a lot of
possibilities
[Music]
we started getting a following but a lot
of radio stations wouldn't play hot
stuff
the sound not only was it new but it was
radically different we were studying
natural harmonics
shiny shiny little music was very heavy
everything he does and that craggly
voice has resonated
that weirdness
it shouldn't have existed in this space
his music sounded like nothing else and
all of a sudden
it would stop like that and the audience
would be dead silent the velvet
underground had hypnotized them
[Music]
always was very clear that there's no
difference between being a writer with a
book and a writer of lyrics
the artist is not with society he's
different
i was interested in communicating to
people who were on the outside
[Music]
which eventually they
good
did
we're your local velvet underground
[Music]
you